good morning John I'm a little bit
pissed off right now okay I'm very
pissed off one of the only things that
make me feel better when I'm very pissed
off is to reorganize my bookshelf so I'm
gonna do that right now
well I hopefully as calmly as possible
explain to you why I'm so pissed off
okay so for those of you who don't know
I have a disease it's a chronic illness
no known cure for it called ulcerative
colitis and it has a whole bunch of
horrible symptoms that you do not want
me to explain to you if you really want
to know you can google it but you
probably just take my word for it
there's medicine for ulcerative colitis
it's called a sykov been taking it for
like five years so the price of a cycle
kept going up and up and up and then a
new drug came on the market called a pre
so and a pre so is basically the same
drug for significantly cheaper so I
switched from a circle to a pre so and
then very soon after I switched the
company made a scale created a new drug
called ethical HD by the way a beautiful
bookshelf all done and they send
everybody hey icicle HD is back it's out
it's just in time for a skull to go
generic and it's even better than as a
call it's basically the exact same thing
but we can call it something different
enough that we can extend our path and
the kicker is a cycle I used to be $300
a month of this is only gonna be $50 a
month
and I was of course ecstatic and so for
the last three months I've been on the
same medication it's been great I love
it I got my auto refill all worked out
at the pharmacy so I walk in the
pharmacy I don't even have to call
beforehand and they get all ready for me
and she's like I got some news for you
I'm afraid that the president this drug
has gone up I'm like I've got a big deal
it used to be $300 and now it's only 50
how much could it it going up these
numbers right here that's how much it's
gone up only 620 for me twelve hundred
percent increase in one month so this is
the patient savings card that lets me
get a skull for $50 a month so I'm
thinking maybe there's something I
missed in the card and there is there's
an expiration date April 1st 2011 which
is funny for a couple of reasons one
because obviously this card expired
before April 1st 2011 second April 1st
2011 is April Fool's Day so they're just
plain old joke on us playing a little
hook on all the people who rely on their
medication do not have horrible painful
lives so this thing that the pharmacist
gave me has a 1-800 number I can call I
call the 800 number and it says I'm
Zahra due to larger than usual call
volume you might have extremely long
wait would you like to leave a message
and one of our representatives will get
back to you ASAP and I was like fine
I'll eat a message answering machine
things said we're sorry the mailbox you
have called is currently full you know
the numbers should do you should call
and it'll be automated message saying
hello thank you for calling we don't
care
so yeah I'm pissed off and I can afford
it and I have extra medication left over
think of all the people who can't afford
it and don't have extra medication left
over what are those people gonna do why
is this okay there's no reason the price
of medication should go up it's the same
medication that they've been making for
20 years they didn't try to contact my
doctor so that we could work something
out before the colossal twelve hundred
percent increase in the cost of
medication and the listed expiration
date on the patient savings card April
Fool's Day was obviously just made up
for fun I'm pissed off enough that I
spent a good part of this weekend
searching for ways to contact Warner
Chilcott Warner Chilcott being the
company that makes this medication and I
managed through the magic of the
internet and some investigative
techniques to find the phone number of
the CEO of Warner Chilcott and I'm gonna
call him right now so I don't expect
Roger Blasio to call me back I did
however find his email address and
emailed him I'm gonna put the email
address in the description below and I
encourage people to think about this
situation complexly um be civil and let
him know how you feel about what his
company's done and hopefully they'll
change the policy and they don't John
nerdfighteria I think we should work
together to make Warner Chilcott daya a
new curse word the only reason the
companies will stop doing BS like this
is if people stand up to it and say that
is not okay John thank you very much I
would appreciate it if you in your next
episode help me understand this
situation complexly and stop being so
pissed off about it because it's hard
when you're on the inside of something
like this and obviously there are much
greater and justices in the world and at
this point I feel like I should
emphasize that this is not a me issue we
can fix me but that's not what we need
to do we need to fix this for everyone
we need to say to these companies that
it's not okay for them to Warner
Chilcott us like that uh-huh I like the
sound of that thanks everyone for your
well wishes John I look forward to your
video on Wednesday